has the villain for the new stargate
series been revealed
welcome to soundtrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so back in november roland emrick had a
series of meetings with amazon and mgm
executives now i told you months ago
that this meeting happened and that he
was pitching a trilogy of movies now the
time we assumed that was for all those
movies to actually get made they were
actually considering making them but i
was told that amazon were never actually
that keen on doing that they did not
want to reboot the series and that's
really only what roland emrick wants to
do
but it turns out that meeting actually
had more to it than just pitching a
trilogy
he was pitching the trilogy but he
wanted to actually pitch it for to be
turned into a tv series
basically in the same way that the idea
for the first movie became sg-1
this new villain is going to become the
bad guy for the new series and this
script this mysterious script that
nobody seems to know who actually wrote
it is already being kicked around the
office at mgm
and has started to get storyboarding
actually have concept art produced for
it
now brad wright's script the stargate
academy idea is also going through the
same process they're storyboarding it
and doing concept art as well
this is being done basically because mgm
and amazon can't make their minds up
which project to go with
do they have do they go with one or the
other or basically work with brad wright
to create a hybrid of both
there's also obviously a possibility
that they could just eventually make
both but i think that's less likely i
think they will try to decide on one
project and i really hope they do here
because at the moment there's a lot of
ideas being bounced around
mgm basically because they've got time
until the mgm amazon sale goes through
they cannot decide on anything so
they're kicking ideas about my only
worries that could actually confuse the
project in the long term i'm really
hoping they focus on one thing at some
point soon and start really
zoning in on it because this is going to
just confuse to mess up a project else
but anyway let's get back to this new
villain
so who is this new villain well we know
a little bit about the second film from
back in the day when roland emerick and
dean devlin were actually in talks to
make him we know it was going to be
called the first gods but who are the
first gods well
roland emmerich does like a bit of an
ancient aliens theory
and the whole thing about the gold was
basically an ancient aliens theory that
aliens had actually been visiting the
earth and they built the pyramids and
this is something that you'll see on
ancient aliens on the history channel um
quite a lot
but there is another major theory within
the ancient aliens arena
that it looks like roland emerick is
focusing on for the second movie and
that we're going to be seeing in this
new series they're called the anunnaki
now the anunnaki were considered the
first gods
there are lots and lots of theories
about this basically derived from a guy
called sichin who says he was able to
translate something called the king's
tablets now this is the oldest writing
in human history from the sumerian or
mesopotamian areas i mean it's thousands
of years old and apparently the king's
tablets
tell the history of the sumerian people
that goes back hundreds and thousands of
years
this story of the anunnaki supposedly
goes into greek mythology and is
basically what our bible is based on
there's a story within the anunnaki
history that um basically the anunnaki
and humans started to breed the anunnaki
giants by the way they're like 12 feet
tall they start to breed and create a
hybrid species between the anunnaki and
humans
enki is the basically the king on the
home world the nibiru
didn't like this so he created a flood
to wipe away
this scourge of this uh you know hybrid
species
basically that flood is what we would
know as the noah's ark story as i say
ronald emerick has already done this
once
this first stargate movie in sg-1 is
basically based on another ancient
aliens theory that mythology run through
most of the series this is a far older
story and i'm sure that this is where
they're gonna go and that mythology will
run through the new series in the same
way it did in the first one
but emeric has also done this another
time because his new movie moonfall is
basically around another ancient alien
story about that actually the moon is
hollow this hollow moon idea that
inspired the movie moonfall basically
comes from um a thing about in the 60s
during one of the apollo missions they
launched they you know to put the lander
on the moon and then the lander came
back up to the pod and it was just a
little coming home they relaunched the
lander and smashed it into the moon and
they had all these seismic sensors and
things they just wanted to see what
would happen
and apparently the moon
quote by a master specialist rang like a
bell and nobody's ever been able to
really quite understand this but some
people have taken that to mean that the
moon is hollow it was built by aliens
and put there to allow humanity to
develop because the moon is very very
important to humans being able to
develop
um it creates the seasons and stabilizes
the planet and all sorts
roland emmerich seems to really like
these ancient alien theories and is more
than happy to turn him into a good movie
but if this is the villain how would i
like to see it being used well the only
nike must have been here before the gold
and the gold came to earth around 10 000
years ago we believe humanity is up to
250 000 years old homo sapiens so the
annunaki could have been here a long
time before the gold
we also know from the ancients that they
arrived and came back to the milky way
and up to 5 million years ago and
repopulated the planet so again we have
a big chunk of time there to play with
but where have the anunnaki been well
i think this is an opportunity to use
the anunnaki sort of like an in-between
maybe they're a bit like the ancients or
the others maybe they've ascended or
partly ascended and they're being come
back for some reason maybe they've come
back to find merlin's weapon
a weapon that could be used against the
ancients
maybe the ancients are holding them back
so the anunnaki want to take their
revenge
or this is a power play that's me just
speculating that's just me spitballing
ideas but i do think this has lots of
opportunities they are going to have to
explain where the yanaki have been for
at least 10 000 years
and this may be
idea that they've ascended or partly
ascended could be an interesting way to
go
so guys get in the comments tell me what
you think do you want to see this new
villain of the anunnaki in stargate do
you think it makes sense there's a lot
of mythology that they can work on by
the way you can become a sidetracker and
support the channel please hit that join
button and if you are new to the channel
please like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out do
all the bunny things and as always guys
please stay safe i'll see you next time